hi guys I'm Erik Bosse and a lot of you
have been asking about fantastic beasts
and where to find them even though I
grew up obsessing over all the Harry
Potter books and films I walked into
this movie blind you know expecting it
to be this small story about one of the
three hufflepuffs anyone ever gave a
crap about playing Pokemon go with
magical animals for two hours I think
your Aggies had shakers turns out not
the case there is way more going on with
this movie with multiple interweaving
storylines tying this story into the
main Harry Potter timeline and don't be
deep into the whole mythology of the
Wizarding World
fenestra and if you walked out of this
movie with a few questions don't worry I
couldn't understand hosts of Eddie
redmayne's mumblecore either so in this
video I'm going to clear up all the big
mysteries and point out how if you've
watched closely enough this movie
sneakily set up all the answers to this
stuff and obviously I'm about to spoil
this entire movie so if you haven't seen
it go watch it and come back here I will
not obliviate you I can but I won't
this is on you okay let's get started
with the first big question what is
going on with graves and Grindelwald so
the biggest twist of the movie comes at
the end when Colin Farrell's character
Percival graves the American horror who
investigates nude in the obscures crisis
who's got his own mysterious ulterior
motives is revealed to be the evil
wizard Gellert Grindelwald in disguise
played by Johnny Depp a lot of people
saw this moment and we're like what the
hell what is Jack Sparrow doing in this
movie did graves ever really exist is
Colin Farrell actually Johnny Depp am I
actually Johnny Depp alright let's break
this down one step at a time
for starters no you're not Johnny Depp
unless you are Johnny Depp in which case
it's pretty cool watching these videos
now is it hard to use like a mouse with
all those rings and bracelets getting
away okay so who is Grindelwald alright
quick refresher here Greenawalt is a
dark wizard who precedes the Harry
Potter series he was friends with Albus
Dumbledore when they were kids some even
think they might have been more than
friends and they would get into Bates
over whether wizards were superior to
muggles and eventually that split them
apart leading to this nasty fight where
curse ricocheted and killed Dumbledore
sister Ariana I'll talk more about her
later Grendel Waltz philosophy was that
wizards were the superior race and that
extremes should be taken for the greater
good like killing and imprisoning a ton
of people basically he's like
wizard Hitler which is also what you
call someone with like a really small
but really long mustache Dumbledore and
Grindelwald met again in 1945 when
Dumbledore defeated him in a famous duel
it's considered to be the most epic
showdown in the history of magic and
Grindelwald was left to rot and one of
the prisons that he built before later
getting killed by Voldemort who is in
search of the Elder Wand now why is the
Elder Wand important all this so we
learned in book 7 that the Elder Wand is
the most powerful wand on earth it's one
of the three Deathly Hallows Grindelwald
stole it from the one maker grigorevich
then lost it in the duel to Dumbledore
who then lost it to Draco Malfoy who
lost it a Harry Potter who then
reclaimed it after defeating Voldemort
who so basically The Sisterhood of the
Traveling wand but in this movie
Grindelwald does not yet possess the
Elder Wand
the one that we see graves use is not
the same nodded wand that we saw
Dumbledore used in the other movies that
was revealed of course to be the elder
one
so Grenoble it hasn't yet stolen it in
this timeline and if he had he would
have been able to kill like way more
people probably wouldn't need to stay in
hiding like this and many people think
the reason Grindelwald is in America in
this movie is to find that one but let's
be clear here in this movie grinned
Wald's main goal is to pose as this top
or Percival graves to stir up trouble
with the obscurest
terrorizing the city of New York to
ignite a war between wizards and no
matches the nomads what no magic they're
not on wizard sorry we call the muggles
just to find the mass slaughter of all
of us normal people meanwhile Percival
graves is a real order who works for
Mikasa that's the American version of
the Ministry of Magic
so Grenoble didn't create this whole
fake identity and go undercover for
decades to like slowly move up the ranks
that would be crazy
or just like really impressive
commitment no it's more likely that
Greenwald is using Polyjuice potion like
how Barty Crouch posed as mad-eye moody
in the Goblet of Fire
or he could be using some other kind of
identity hiding spell that we don't know
about and seeing how willing Greenwald
was to kill to cover his tracks my guess
is the real graves is probably dead
someone really should check his
apartment now once you understand this
Graves is sometimes confusing actions
start to make a lot more sense like yeah
it was super abrupt for Graves to
sentence Newton Tina death but it was a
direct consequence of the moment before
when he accidentally let's lit that the
obscurus is
quote and newt notices his
disappointment so this is all
Grindelwald just covering his tracks in
fact that moment was just one of the
many clues throughout the movie that
were shadowed graves his true identity
and here the other ones that I caught
so first the haircut and the first scene
of the movie we see this reversed shot
of the back of Greenwald's head and a
few scenes later we see the same shot
showing the back up graves his head with
a similar haircut and the director
explained that there's a reason why they
wanted this haircut in particular
because it was the same cut worn by
members of the Hitler Youth in Germany
and they wanted Grindelwald x' rise to
mirror the nazis then we get this first
establishing shot of graves and it's
this menacing image of him posing in the
frame of the rebel with his cape
flapping in the wind but also why does
graves go up through the second-story
when all the other investigators go
through the ground-level I think it's
because they wanted this shot to evoke
the iconic image of Grindelwald from
deathly hallows in the window frame as
he stole the elder one from grigorevich
the next clue is graves is weirdly
extremist philosophy so early in the
film Graves tells credence and this is
clearly foreshadowing what we know to be
Grindelwald secret philosophy that
Wizards shouldn't have to hide in the
shadows that they should be out in the
open as the dominant class in society
and using the obscure ease to start this
war between wizards and humans is the
most direct path to that new social
order and then later in the movie newt
senses that Graves is trying to accuse
him of being a follower greenwald and
then he says mascota the greater good
you mean and that particular phrasing
strikes a chord with graves because the
greater good is something that
Grindelwald says all the time and then
of course the deathly hallows necklace
graves gives it2 credence as a way to
communicate and this is really the
smoking gun for Grindelwald we know from
book 7 that that is his mark he's
obsessed with finding the deathly
hallows and then we see his fighting
skill and this happened omus before we
found out who he was anyway but the way
graves takes on several ores at once and
if Newt hadn't surprised him he probably
would have killed all them not many
Wizards are this powerful and a look on
picker EES face suggests that she's
already realizing who he is and then
there's lots of little shots throughout
the film such as wind picker II warns
about war and graves his expression
seems to be one of Approval signaling
that this is actually what he wants and
then later during the assembly atma Kusa
picker ii accuses the delegate of
letting Gellert Grindelwald slip through
his fingers and we Emil
eally cut to a shot of graves looking
mysterious and brooding and then while
interrogating newt graves asked what
makes Albus Dumbledore so fun of you and
he pauses on Dumbledore's name clearly
thinking about their past friendship now
here's another big question people are
asking about Grindelwald what do his
final words to newt mean as he's taken
away Grendel while turns to Newt and he
says so this is super mysterious and my
first thought was that Greenwald's just
a huge fan of Faith Hill but seriously
some people are saying this could be a
reference to Grindelwald desire to
become new master over death by
acquiring the Deathly Hallows or maybe
that he created Horcrux like Voldemort
will and that killing him will only make
him die just a little but I think
there's a reason he says it's to Newt in
particular it's because he knows that
Newt has a relationship with Dumbledore
so I predict that will we die just a
little is a reference to a past exchange
between Grindelwald and Dumbledore and
Newt will repeat this phrase to
Dumbledore and we'll learn what it all
means in the next movie which leads me
to another question people are asking
what will happen in the sequels so
fantastic beasts is just the first of
five planned movies for this franchise
and from what we can tell the future of
the series seems to be focused on
Grindelwald and Dumbledore specifically
they're inevitable famous showdown in
1945 and that explains why Johnny Depp
was cast in the part which confused a
few of you the producer specifically
wanted an iconic actor with a history of
playing mysterious seductive devilish
characters and someone who can carry a
franchise and rumor has it that they're
in the process of casting an actor to
play young Albus Dumbledore that brings
up another question will Newt Scamander
be in the sequels so even though Newt
apparently won't be the main focus of
the franchise we know he will definitely
appear at least in the next movie and
from reading the past Harry Potter books
Newt does live a long life he's still
alive in the present day or at least
through 2015 his grandson actually
marries Luna Lovegood but there are
still more mysteries to news story that
it looks like the next movie we'll dig
into specifically what is newts
connection to Lidl estranged so we
learned from the scene where queenie
reads newts mind that he was close
friends with Lidl estranged when they
were at Hogwarts together and JK Rowling
tweeted that Lita would be in the next
movie so who is she now remember the
Lestrange family has a history of dark
wizards like Rudolph is Lestrange
husband to Bella
strange and the two of them tortured
neville longbottom parents but Newt says
that both he and Leda were Outsiders
that's how they got along so my
prediction is Leda has a love-hate
relationship with her own evil family
like she's the rare white sheep of the
lestranges we also learned from Grace's
questioning that Newt got expelled from
Hogwarts for endangering lives with a
beast but Rowling hinted that Newt was
blamed for something that he didn't do
he took the blame for something someone
else did so it seems like Newt took the
fall for something that Leda might have
done which might be why Queenie called
her a taker it's pretty clear the next
movie will answer these questions about
Newt and Leda okay let's move on to
another question you guys had why is the
obscurest important in this story so
from a narrative standpoint the
obscurest mystery is what brings Newt
Scamander and Graves slash Grindelwald
together as a matches ooh ologist Newt
is the one who identifies the mysterious
force as an obscurest the manifestation
of a young wizard or witch is anxiety
over suppressing their powers and it's
the old obscurus and newts collection
that gets him briefly blamed for the
crisis and he knows how to approach
obscure eels gently and talk them down
meanwhile Graves wants to locate the
obscure eel and use the obscurest to
start a war so the two of them end up
being on opposite sides of that problem
but the reason JK rowling put the
concept of an obscurus into this movie
goes deeper than that it's tied to the
decision to set the story in America so
superstition and religious frenzy over
witchcraft goes back to the early days
of America with the Salem witch trials
when women in colonial Massachusetts
were accused of witchcraft and
persecuted Rowling created the idea of
an obscurest as a reflection of this
dark violent period in American history
when abused and scared children would be
forced to hide their magical powers but
also Rowling frames credence is obscurus
as a reflection of another recurring
theme in her work child abuse so this
isn't as clear in the movies but in the
books especially the earlier ones they
really focus on Harry Potter's miserable
life with the Dursleys and how they
abuse him both verbally and with awful
living conditions and abuse toward
children comes back throughout the
series with Dolores Umbridge using cruel
corporal punishment in order to Phoenix
and the Carrows ordering the use of the
Cruciatus curse on the first years in
Deathly Hallows
similarly this movie doesn't shy away
from mrs. bare-bones physical abuse of
credence and the obscures
becomes a visual metaphor for credenzas
inner turmoil and rage and before we
move on a quick detail I liked about the
obscurus before credence it was only
known to affect children under the age
of 10 and if you remember 11 is the age
most magical kids begin their education
schools like Hogwarts would teach them
how to channel and express and use their
magical powers freely so it makes sense
that this would be a problem that would
only affect kids who wouldn't had a
chance to learn to control their magic
yet and this brings up another theory
people were asking about was Dumbledore
sister and obscure you so there's a
chapter in Deathly Hallows when
Dumbledore's brother Abe report talked
about how Albus his sister Ariana was
attacked by a group of muggle boys when
she was six and it traumatized her into
hiding her magic and this exact
description seems very interesting now
it destroyed her what they did she was
never right again she wouldn't use magic
but she couldn't get rid of it it turned
inward and drove her mad it exploded out
of her when she couldn't control it and
at times she was strange and dangerous
that sounds a lot like newts description
for obscure eels and pretty much a
character profile for credence now the
big hang-up is that Ariana lived until
she was 14 and all recorded incidents of
obscure eels died by the age of 10 but
if Ariana was still undiagnosed this
could be true
and I'm thinking Rowling might address
this in future movies like with
Dumbledore and Grindelwald recalling
this tragic history or maybe she'll
confirm it in an interview the way she
outed Dumbledore little Bane guy coming
on something completely hell I want to
move on to another strange moment of the
movie why is it okay that Newt and Tina
gets sentenced to die to me this is the
biggest what the moment of fantastic
beasts right like graves could just
sentence Newt and Tina died so quickly
with no trial or jury and McHugh so has
this creepy execution room set up and
that no one stops to ask how the hell is
this legal now here's how I look at this
for one I think Graves may have just
been acting unilaterally here trying to
kill nude and Tina when they started to
suspect something was off about him
and that President Pickering probably
wouldn't have approved of this but also
I think this movie is using this to show
how dangerous of a wartime this is so
notice all the shots of this threat
clock in the maquis Lobby a lot of
people are just saying that this is a
reference to the Weasley clock but I
think this has more historical
significance like it seems to be a
combination of the nuclear clock which
expressed tensions between the United
States and the Soviet Union during the
Cold War but also the
our coded terror alert system after 9/11
in both cases civil liberties like the
right to a fair trial or protection from
cruel and unusual punishment we're often
suspended when it came to matters of
national security and by the way a lot
of you were wondering why the whole
election subplot with the Shah family is
part of this story this is all about
reinforcing this context with the
magic-related death of a rising
political star bringing these two worlds
to the brink of war and just to break
down what we're seeing here the process
works like a pen see where positive
memories are drawn from the person's
mind and used to lure them into this
death potion that's like using old
family photos to lure someone into an
electric chair criminal justice in the
Wizarding World is super cup guys okay
one last question I want to talk about
why can Kowalski's still remember things
at the end of the movie so one of my
favorite parts of this movie is the last
scene when Kowalski has opened the
bakery the fantastic beasts he
encountered with Newt have inspired
pastries and he has this vague
recognition upon seeing Queenie so why
is he remembering these things so the
simple answer to this is that the venom
from the swooping evil may have
obliviated things from his conscious
memory but little details still hang
around in his dreams and subconscious
that would be a sweet poetic
justification but this actually works on
another more literal level too so Newt
uses his Thunderbird to create a
rainstorm and spread the venom of the
swooping evil over the city and if you
remember earlier in the film he told
Kowalski that it only washes away bad
memories so while everyone in the city
only saw the bad side of magic as it
like destroyed property and hurt people
Kowalski saw a nicer less scary more
lovely aspect of magic so all the other
no matches memories were totally cleared
but Kowalski forgot any of the scary
moments and retained the nice parts like
the wonder of all these magical beasts
and the love that he felt for Queenie
okay so those are the big mysteries I
found interesting in fantastic beasts
let me know if you have any other
questions or theories of your own
seriously I love talking Harry Potter
I'm a huge Potter head and in case you
were wondering I was sorted into
ravenclaw and Thunderbird my Patronus is
a black stallion and my wand is a Rowan
wood with a dragon heartstring core 13
inches and slightly springy flexibility
ladies so if you liked this video please
hit like and subscribe to new rockstars
and share this video with all your
friends
keep the discussion going guys also you
can contribute to us on our patreon page
big thanks to all of our current patrons
you guys are the best so you can hit me
up on Twitter at EA boss with any
thoughts you had on fantastic beasts or
follow new rock stars on Twitter for
updates on our videos ok thanks for
watching bye